[موسيقى]
بدات حياه المهنيه بعمر 18 سنه
اخترت ادرس الاعلام
ليش
ببساطه
الصوره الذهنيه
تعرضت باساساتها
بنت صغيره بعمر الخمسه سنين
بنتك فاشله
يعني فشل
بس فهمك تعابير وجه امها الي تغيرت
ست سنين سبع سنين ثمانيه سنين تسع سنين
العمر العشر سنين في يوم بيكون في اجتماع
لاولياء الامور
على التطور الاكاديمي عندها وبعرفها شاطره
عليها
البنت كانت تتوقعه انه ملامح ابوها تكون
سعيده بس فجاه بنادي عليها
بدي اياك تروحي لاخر الممر
وتحكي معي باعلى صوتك
احكي
احكي مش سامع
البنت تسمرت محلها
كل الانظار كانت عليها
وسكتت
بهذيك اللحظه هالصوت هذا الصوت
كم واحد فيكم
بشوف حاله محلها البنت
خوفو من انه يقدم مشروعه في شركه
او
ابنه مبدعين بس عندهم
انهم يطوروا من مهاراتهم الخطاب كم واحد
يرفع ايديكم
كم واحد
خمسه عشره 20 30
واحد من اصل 20 شخص
والخوف عند مواجهه الاخرين من اطياف عمريه
مختلفه وذلك بحسب المعهد الوطني
عنده فرط نشاط في جزء من الدماغ
يسمى بالفصل اللوزي او الام
وهو الجزء المسؤول عن الادراك
وتقييم العواطف الحسيه والمدارس
عند الشعور بالخوف والقلق
كيف هذا الكلام بينعكس على صاحبه
واحد
الخوف من اراء الاخرين
اثنين
الارتباك وعدم الاداء بفاعليه ودقه
قلب الثقه بالنفس
واربعه الانسحاب وعدم مواجهه الاخرين
خمسه وفي اقصى حالاتها انعدام الحياه
الاجتماعيه
من الخوف نعم
انا هي هاي البنت اللي بعمر الخمس سنين
بتروح من الافكار
وبتتبعثر الكلمات
كيف اتجاوز خوفي عند التحدث امام الجمهور
ومواجهه الاخرين
الاجابه على هالسؤال كانت اول خطوه
لتحويل خوفي الى جسر لا حاجز امام طموحي
[تصفيق]
جماعه اراء الناس في المجال الاعلامي
القصص الانسانيه
كله ورد راح تلاقي الناس المحيطه اللي
حاولوا يهبطوا من عزيزته الفعل في مرحله
معينه وصلت فيها بعد 14 سنه من المجال
الاعلامي
وصلت لمرحله انه لسه في اصوات لليوم اللي
بتحاول انها ترجعك لورا
تخليك لا اراديا تنسحب
بدي ادعم الجانب العملي بالجانب المعرفي
كملت الدراسات العليا
بدكم الحل صح حكينا كيف اتجاوز خوفي عند
التحدث امام الجمهور
البدايه من الخيال
كان ولا يمكن اوصل للي انا وصلت اليوم وان
شاء الله لسه طريق قدامي طويله الا بالخير
صوره ذهنيه
اول من خرج في هذا المصطلح وداع اليه شخص
يدعى لبنان
اطلق العنان لخيالك
رسوم صوره ذهنيا الي بدك توصلوا
بدات مع فئه الاطفال في التدريبات كنت
اجيب صوره واحكي لهم طلعوا على هالصوره
وشو بتشوفوا فيها
تتفاجئه مع انه هن كلهم بنفس الفئه
العمريه لكل واحد كان عنده تصور مختلفه عن
الاخر
المدارس
لهيك لازم اوقف التصور والخيال عنده
بلشنا معهم بالصوره الذهنيه عن انفسهم
الواحد من الاطفال بكون خربش بعطيك ورقه
رسمه كلها خرابيش هو بالنسبه له
مكوك فضائي فيها بس انت كبير
مع الفراغ العمري
هذا الراي اللي هز ثقتي بنفسي وانا عمري
خمس سنين هل راي انا مهم لحتى اجي اطفش
هذا الطفل ولا يمكن
المهم
البدايه بتكون من عند الاطفال
فاللي ابنه او بنته خجولين انا متاكده
تماما انه انتم بتثقوا في قدراتهم ولكن
البدايه
بالتواصل الفعال
في مجال الاعلامي بنحكي رساله او مرسل
رساله مستقبل بس هالشكل التقليدي هذا
بطل صالح للاستعمال لازم ندخل العامل
الثاني القفل الثاني اللي عندنا لازم انه
نوظفه عشان نفتح الباب بالنهايه
العامل الثاني هو التعبير
التعبير عن افكارنا الطفل باولها بكون شوي
شوي يجمع بكلماته اذا مش بالكلمات بالرسم
بالملتينه ولا يمكن اليوم تروح على روضه
او حتى حضانه الا بعضهم ملفينيا
بدهم يحكوا
فجبت نفس الاطفال
حكت لهم تعالوا بدي احكي لكم قصه
ما كملتها
لكم
وتعبروا لي برايكم
كيف ممكن ننهي القصه
كل واحد منها الاطفال كان عنده رؤيه
الخاصه
وهو الالقاء
فن الالقاء واللي هو عاملين الكلام
المنطوق ولغه الجسدته
الكلام المنطوق اني انا ارد بكلامي مقدمه
جذابه قصه ارقام صادمه نسب ممكن انها تسبب
يعني صدمه عند الناس
ولكن لغه الجسد لها ايضا لغه هي لغه احنا
ما بنوظفها بالشكل الصح
تعرف الابواب الحديد القديمه
بيكون في قفل من فوق صوره ذهنيه
تعبير
المفتاح
انت صاحب هذا المفتاح
الماضي ولا يمكن انه نغيره
ولكن بامكان نرسم المستقبل
الله سبحانه وتعالى قال في كتابه العزيز
ان الله لا يغير ما بقوم حتى يغيروا ما
بانفسهم صدق الله العظيم شكرا